[Musique]
après 9 jours de marche et neuf étapes
tout autour de l'île les membres du
Secours Catholique terminent leur
périple au jardin de l'État une belle
aventure humaine pour ses familles et
ses bénévoles qui placent cette action
sous le signe de la fraternité pendant
ces 9 jours en fait on a décidé de faire
des marches fraternelles donc tout
autour de lîle donc en part du python de
neige et en venant sur Saint-Denis
aujourd'hui donc ça a été neuf étapes de
marche avec un fil conducteur qui a été
la la solidarité donc qui est un très
important pour nous donc la solidarité
pour différents publics donc les jeunes
la famille les personnes âgées et puis
toutes les personnes quel que soit leurs
croyan et puis on a décidé aussi de
faire ces marches pour rom rompre
l'isolement des personnes et où ouvrir
l'accès à la culture au loisirs
notamment à travers différentes
activités donc l'intervention de
compteurs d'histoire créole de chanteurs
mais aussi à travers différentes
activités telles que les piquenique donc
les piquniques créoles qui sont très
importants pour nous à la Réunion
Raymond clin est bénévole depuis 20 ans
au Secours catholique et c'est encore
avec beaucoup d'énergie qu'elle termine
cette marche solidaire on a commencé
depuis les se
on est arrivé les 15 avec B hum bon
équipe super ambiance merci à vous
merci de
[Musique]
V
plaisir je ré avec l'équipeon é tous
formid et quel souvenir vous gardez de
de cette marche c'est l'ambiance
familiale vraiment fraternelle Mar
fraternelle d'accord il y a eu des
rencontres des moments d'échange
qu'est-ce que des rencontres inter
équipe il y en a qui arrivent il y en a
qui qui s'en vant et il reviennent on a
fait tout le temps des connaissances
mais toujours avec humour une super
ambiance tous les bénévoles et les
familles accueillies par le Secours
catholique se sont donnés rendez-vous au
jardin de l'État pour fêter les 70 ans
de l'association c'est un événement
puisque le Secours Catholique fête
aujourd'hui sur le plan national c'est
70 ans et à la limite je dirais que pour
la Réunion c'est un double événement
parce que les 70 ans national et les 60
ans à la Réunion puisque le Secours
Catholique a été créé en 1946 sur le
plan national et c'est 10 ans après
seulement que la Réunion donc a vu la
naissance de de son son association ici
tous réunis autour d'un piquenique géant
normalement pour le piquenique c'est pas
moi qui a prévu c'est ma ma copine qui a
prévu mais r aussi c'est un RAL pomme de
terre et c'est bien de faire un
pique-nique comme ça tous ensemble ah
c'est vraiment le rêve là on on trouve
en sœur en famille et vraiment super
salade de riz avec ce qu'il avait à la
maison le thon le jambon le riz les
tomates et du citron voilà et du
Reblochon de Savoie qui sent bon mais
seulement c'est dans sa
boîte depuis 60 ans le Secours
Catholique s'engage dans
l'accompagnement social des réonnés en
difficulté 340 bénévoles donnent
quotidiennement de leur temps pour aider
et œuvrer à un meilleur vivre ensemble
au sein de la sociité j'ai donné mon
temps à aider les autres et ça vous
apporte quoi d'aider les autres ah
j'étais toujours contente toujours
contente ça me fait plaisir d' des mon
prochain c'est pour préparer mon chemin
aussi peut-être un
jour de toute façon on sera jamais
perdant quand on aide les autres ça fait
toujours de la joie et tu rentres chez
toi toujours en en paix aussi parce que
tu as pu faire quelque chose tu as pu
rendre service à quelqu'un ça nous app
nous apporte nous apporte beaucoup
d'être bénévoolle parce que nous aimons
euh soutenir les autr le contact la
relation l'accueil avec les autres et et
pour les les mettre debout alors hein
nous à Plateau Caillou on fait pas mal
d'activités euh nous on fait des
rencontre intergénération rencontre
convivial on fait des sorties inter
générationnelles on on on fait l'accueil
et
puis visite à domicile visite dans les
hôpitaux les maisons de retraite et
vacances famille alors les actions que
le Secours Catholique mène aujourd'hui à
la Réunion sont des actions autour de C
priorités les familles les jeunes les
personnes âgées donc les gramounes le
l'emploi et la solidarité internationale
en particulier dans la zone Océan Indien
dans le cadre de ces actions on a des
donc toute une première partie qui va
être l'accueil des familles pour un
petit peu mieux les connaître voir
quelle est le situation de quoi ils ont
besoin mais aussi comment eux peuvent
être acteurs en fait de leur propre
projet et à partir de là on va voir
effectivement de quelle manière on va
pouvoir répondre soit individuellement
soit leur proposer aussi des actions
collectives dans lesquelles ils vont
s'impliquer
[Musique]